welcome to deconstructing chatbots I'm
Priyanka reg area and today's episode is
a special one because we are going to
visit spring Elmo's office in Pleasanton
California and sit down with Dhruv
Ahmadi
their expert at managing conversational
AI projects stay tuned because we will
talk about real-world use cases of
conversational AI how some of them have
come to life starting from the idea to
the finished experience without further
delay let's go and chat with drew my
name is Ruth Ahmadi I'm a technical
project manager at Spring ml Springer
Mel is a Google cloud from your partner
in advanced analytics and machine
learning we work on AI n ml use cases
across you know computer vision chat box
predictive modeling increasingly data
migration as well you know we founded
the company about four years ago now
started as a small you know local team
of less than 10 employees we've grown
exponentially since then we're about a
hundred folks all over the globe for
different offices and you know it's it's
been an exciting journey we feel like
we're just getting started in a lot of
ways that the founders started with a
core belief that machine learning and
artificial intelligence will really
transform the way you know enterprises
do business in the future and that's
really our mission is to help them you
know incorporate AI nml across their
business Google is probably the leader
in AI n ml and we leveraged a lot of the
best school technologies from tensorflow
to auto ml to dial up flow for building
chatbots and really helped customers
accelerate the time they see impact
we've seen use cases both you know b2b
as well as consumer chatbots spanning a
number of different industries from
retail to banking to pharmaceutical one
that we did recently for a big pharma
company helping their product managers
easily retrieve information about
different drug studies as well as
regulatory hurdles
we also worked on a cool consumer broth
for a retailer and helping them provide
a gift recommender for the customers I
think the biggest learning as I see it
is that design is fundamental to
building any successful chat but you
know unlike traditional IVR systems you
know chat BOTS can handle nonlinear
conversations and so really working with
business stakeholders to figure out what
the ideal conversation flow looks like
will be essential to building that that
thought that works for for the users
[Music]
today at Spring EMA office in Pleasanton
it's such a nice day today absolutely
really nice so what do you mean that
conversation flow how do you design a
conversation we ask a number of
different questions initially right off
the bat first you want to understand you
know what are the key business
objectives of the chat pod
what is your workflow life will a human
be part of the process or should the
bought be able to handle all questions
then we move to some more tactical types
of things so how many unique types of
questions do you want the bot to handle
you know our most those questions static
is there a general response for a
question or are the dynamic questions so
is it dependent on the specific
information that the user provides so
like connecting to a back-end database
or some absolutely
once you have like kicked off a project
what do you see as some of the
implementation recommendations that you
provide to users so if you're a new
customer you know we recommend that you
start with a four week PLC just to kind
of showcase the art of what is possible
you know maybe throw in some static and
dynamic questions for some variety we
start with you know a week of
requirement gathering followed by a
couple weeks of agile development we'll
take your feedback into into account and
finally a week of user acceptance
testing just to make sure that users are
comfortable and everything is working
effectively what happens after maybe a
month or so sure so after about a month
that's when we move into a production
phase so that'll be a couple more months
where we add
more questions both static and dynamic
you know we may add a user interface and
then you know we may release the bot
through multiple channels including
Google assistant and Google home but
others like facebook Messenger and
select sued review show you talked about
a little bit in terms of how to
implement the chat bots you've talked
about some examples can you show me a
back-end infrastructure and architecture
of an implemented chat bot absolutely
let me show you awesome all right we are
with Drew and he's gonna walk us through
how some of these chat BOTS work yeah so
let's take a look at one that we did for
a coffee shop uh coffee I love coffee
yeah that's - absolutely that's what the
chat well will do for you so so this
chat pod basically helps the coffee shop
automate their customer service awesome
so as you can see we have aggregated
some of the most popular items at the
bottom here just to allow you to easily
select one of the items so for example
if you want to order a couple donuts you
can select the item at the bottom
and as you can see to the right
we're basically showing you your order
in real time so you can see how much
you're paying and the front end is it
created with App Engine it is yes so
this is deployed on App Engine okay and
you know one other item that's kind of
cool is you can select what's most
popular this week so for that we're able
to aggregate overall data over the past
week and figure out you know what was
the most ordered item oh that is amazing
would you need you to see what that was
Chuck okay click on that oh wow it looks
like some more glazed donuts I think
I've had enough for today yeah so that
actually the coffee shop demo itself was
pretty enlightening to understand how
the front-end would work can you show me
an example which talks about a little
bit of back-end behind-the-scenes stuff
absolutely so we actually did a chat pod
recently for a Google internal team for
Google collections and really what this
chat pods does is it helps Google
customers easily look up their account
information invoice details details
about their account in general you know
and for example if you're you know a
customer at Telemark you can easily look
up information specific to tell Mart and
only once you're authenticated as a
telomere customer okay so what does the
front-end look like for that one so for
that one we go to the bot so as you can
see this is a main Google Health page
and to the bottom left we have a section
for Google actions yeah so you can click
on that and then you have to log in with
your details and again only if you're a
Telemark customer are you authenticated
to to see telomer invoices so in this
case we'll use
those email details and now we're on the
main Google collections page and I see
the chat window that can come up
absolutely so it's a pop-up at the
bottom right so if you click on the
pop-up you can now start using the chat
log Oh perfect so before we actually
start to use the chat pod with talimar
as an example can you show some of the
vaccum interpret interconnections
between the dialogue flow interface and
the front-end and what's what's in the
behind-the-scenes absolutely so you know
basically users are interacting with the
web UI deployed an app engine
now that app engine layer sits on top of
dialogue flow and dialogue flow is where
all of the user questions are are
built-in now dialogue flow integrates to
a couple of applications it integrates
to bigquery in this case bigquery is
where all of our data is stored all the
information around account details and
invoices and then the actual documents
themselves they're stored in cloud
storage and what that does is basically
allows us to email those documents back
to the user after big asked questions
okay so are you gonna show the example
where we see the email coming up
absolutely let's take a look say I
wanted to find my latest invoices should
ask for a company name so we're at
Cellmark and as you can see the chaplet
responds with the three latest unpaid
invoices so the invoice numbers the due
date as well as the amounts and then if
you go to your email
you can see that those just arrived you
can take a look at the copies that is
perfect can we also look at dialogue
flow interface and some of the intents
that were created in there yes
absolutely it's as you can see each of
these items here are different intents
so in that latest invoices example if
you click on it
[Music]
so we fed in some different training
phrases so those are different ways that
a user can ask the particular question
you know recent invoice latest unpaid
invoices and as I mentioned before the
cool thing about dialogue flow is that
it has the AML Nai capability to learn
over time so if you ask something
similar it should know that that's you
know latest invoices is one factor
you're asking for well awesome that was
great thank you so much for giving us
all that information starting from how
you started to design the BOD up to the
point where how you created these
integrations with Babbitt bigquery as
well as with GCS thanks through for
walking us through that amazing demo we
welcome well I hope you enjoyed the tips
and tricks shared by Dhruv today to
bring your conversationally I use case
to life we cannot wait to hear more
about your specific use case in the
comments below if you liked this video
and would like to see more such content
don't forget to Like and subscribe to
our Channel
[Music]